today we're talking about data sets
bigquery and managing vms i'm alicia and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
with google cloud's data sets you can
access an ever expanding collection of
data to support and empower your
analyses and ml models
the most recent edition is all of google
cloud's release notes
make sure you bookmark this blog post
because we're keeping it up to date with
data set news and best practices
interested in checking out those data
sets but aren't quite sure where to
start
leah has been busy bringing us all kinds
of tips on how to architect and
administer bigquery whether you're new
to bigquery or just looking to brush up
these blogs and videos will help you
become a bigquery expert
the cloud is full of new and exciting
technologies which can help you innovate
and save we just published a full guide
of different ways to help you manage
your virtual machines and save some
money by not paying for resources you're
not using
from simply pausing machines that aren't
needed to building an automated solution
with recommender find the best way to
optimize your usage with this guide
if you're building an app and need a
relational database cloud sql has what
you need it's a fully managed relational
database for mysql postgresql and sql
server and if you're looking for some
tips on how it works or how to migrate
check out these resources from priyanka
and gabe
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the links any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you